الان ادعوك سيدتي
من الموافقه على طلب الدكتوره حسيم سعاده
الدكتور شكرا الان ندعو الدكتوره هديله
حسيم
ل مخاطبه المحكمه
تفضلي
شكرا حضره الرئيسه والاع
المقرون انه
لشرف لي ان امثل دوله جنوب افريقيا في هذه
القضيه الاستثنائيه التي تشدد على جوهر
انسانيتنا
المشتركه مثل ما جاء في مقدمه اتفاقيه
الاباده واجبي ان اتوجه الى المحكمه
للحديث عن الافعال التي التي ادت الى
تقديم هذا الطلب بموجب الماده ال 41
للنظام الاساسي
للمحكمه براي جنوب افريقيا انتهكت اسرائيل
الماده الثانيه ل الاتفاقيه وذلك بارتكاب
افعال تبين نمطا منهجيا للسلوك يمكن منه
تحقيق الاباده اسمحوا لي ان اضع هذه
الافعال في السياق غزه هي من جزئين من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله التي تحتلها
اسرائيل منذ العام
67 انها قطاع ضيق يمتد او مساحته حوالي
365 كيلومترا مربعا مثلما يظهر على
الخارطه المعروضه الان امامنا تواصل اسرا
ممارسه
سيطرتها
على المساحه المعابر المياه الاقليميه
الكهرباء النطاق الكهرومغناطيسي والبنى
التحتيه المدنيه في غزه
وفي المناصب الحكوميه الرئيسيه مثل ما ذكر
معالي الوزير الدخول
والخروج برا
وجوا الى غزه
ممنوع عبر
معبرين تتحكم بهما اسرائيل غزه تعتبر من
الاماكن الاكثر اظاظا في العالم وفيها
حوالي 2.3 مليون فلسطيني اكثر من نصفهم
تقريبا من الاطفال خلال الايام ال96
الماضيه عرضت اسرائيل غزه لما وصف بانه
اكثف حمله قصف في ت تاريخ الحروب المعاصره
الفلسطينيون في غزه يقتلون بالقنابل
والقصف
والغارات جوا برا
وبحرا وهم معرضون لخطر الموت نتيجه الجوع
والعطش والامراض كنتيجه للحصار المستمر من
اسرائيل تدمير القرى
الفلسطينيه والمساعدات غير
التي يسمح بوصولها الى السكان الفلسطينيين
وعدم امكانيه توزيع المساعده المحدوده في
ظل سقوط القنابل والقذائف
هذا يجعل من غير الممكن الحصول على
الضرورات الاساسيه للبقاء على
الحياه مثل ما اوضحت هذه المحكمه في قضيه
جامبيا ميانمار وفي هذه الظروف ليس من
الضروري الوصول الى حكم نهائي حول اذا ما
تشكل يشكل سلوك اسرائيل وافعالها اباده
ولكن من الضروري فقط ان نحدد اذا ما كان
على الاقل جزء من هذه الافعال ينطوي في اط
او ينطوي ويدرج في اطار احكام
الاتفاقيه هذه الافعال التي يشتكى منها
تجعل واضح ان عندما ننظر اليها ان البعض
منها ان لم يكن جميعها يدرج في اطار هذه
الاحكام وهذه الافعال موثقه بالتفصيل في
الطلب الذي تقدمت به جنوب افريقيا وتم
التاكد منها من مصادر موثوقه بمعظمها او
غالبا من الامم المتحده ومن غير الممكن ان
اعددها جميعا سوف ا سلط الضوء على البعض
منها من اجل تصوير نمط هذا السلوك
الابادي احصائيات الامم المتحده التي
نعتمد عليها محدثه لغايه التاسع من يناير
[موسيقى]
في م رفعات الشفهيه
سوف نحض قدر الامكان الاعتماد على الادله
الادله بالصور والفيديوهات وسنفعل ذلك فقط
عندما يكون ذلك ضر
وبما يلتزم باحترام الشعب الفلسطيني على
هذه الخلفيه انتقل
الان لابين كيف ان سلوك اسرائيل يشكل
انتهاكا للماده 2 الف 2 ب 2 ج وث د
للاتفاقيه الفعل الاول الذي ترتكبه
اسرائيل هو القتل الجماعي للفلس
في غزه بما يشكل انتهاكا للماده 2 الف في
الاتفاقيه مثل ما فسر الامين العام للامم
المتحده منذ خمسه اسابيع مستوى القتل على
يد اسرائيل كبير لدرجه انهما من مكان امن
في غزه اقف امامكم
اليوم وقد قتل
23 فلسطينيا على يد القوات او الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال الهجمات على مدى ثلاثه
اشهر المنصرمه على الاقل 70% من هؤلاء من
النساء
والاطفال حوالي 7000 فلسطيني مازالوا في
عدد المفقودين يفترض انهم ماتوا تحت
الانقاض عرضوا الفلسطينيون في غزه لقصف لا
يتوقف اينما ذهبوا يقتلون في منازلهم في
مكان الذي يلجؤون اليه في المستشفيات في
المدارس في المساجد في
الكنائس وفي محاوله وهم يحاولون ايجاد
الغذاء والمياه لعائلاتهم يقتلون ان لم
يخلوا
المكان يقتلون في الاماكن
لجوا اليها وحتى في محاوله
فرارهم على الطرق التي تدعي اسرائيل انها
امنه القتل كبير لدرجه ان الجثث التي يتم
ايجادها تدفن في مقابر جماعيه من دون
التعرف عليها في الاسابيع الثلاثه الاولى
بعد السابع من اكتوبر نشرت اسرائيل ست او
قصفت اسرائيل قنبله اسبوعيا وهذا بمقدار
200 مره
اكثر عفوا
2 قنبله في مناطق اعتبرت امنه
للفلسطينيين وقد استهدفت الشمال بما في
ذلك
ال مخيمات هذه القناب القنابل والقذائف هي
من الاكثر دمويه ودمارا تسقطها الطائرات
المقاتله التي تستهدف اهدافا على الميدان
ويستخدمها احد الجيوش التي لديها اكبر
الموارد لقد استهدفت
اسرائيل وهي تعرف
عدد المدنيين الذين ستقتل هذه القنابل
اكثر من 1800 عائله فلسطينيه في غزه خسرت
اكثر من فرد واحد من افرادها ومئات من
العائلات عبر الاجيال محيت بالكامل من دون
ان يبقى اي شخص على قيد الحياه امهات اباء
اطفال اشقاء اجداد
خالات اولاد عام وعمات غالبا ما قتلوا
معا هذا القتل
يضاف يشكل دمارا للحياه الفلسطينيه ويرتكب
عن قسط لا يستثنى احد ولا حتى
الرضع مستوى قتل الاطفال في غزه وصف
كمقبلات من امين عام الامم المتحده هذا
الوصف
كارثي لا يبرر باي مسوق قانوني او حتى
انساني الفعل الثاني المرتكب الذي يذكر في
طلب جنوب افريقيا هو التسبب باضرار جسديه
ونفسيه جسيمه ضد الفلسطينيين في غزه ويشكل
انتهاكا للماده الثانيه ب في
الاتفاقيه ولدت الهجمات اكثر من 36 ال من
الاص اابات ومجددا بمعظمهم من النساء
والاطفال هذا في فتره انهار فيه ايضا
القطاع الصحي وسات طرق الى ذلك لاحقا في
خطابي عدد كبير من المدنيين الفلسطينيين
بمن فيهم
الاطفال يتم
توقيفهم تقفل اعينهم يجبرون على نزع
منازلهم يتم وضعهم في الشاحنات وياخذون
الى اماكن غير معروفه معاناه الفلسطينيين
الجسديه والنفسيه لا يمكن
نكرانها انتقل الى الفعل الثالث بموجب
الماده اين جيم فرضت اسرائيل ظروف لا تسمح
بمواصله
الحياه و وهدفها تحقيق الدمار تحقق
اسرائيل ذلك باربعه اساليب على الاقل اولا
من خلال
النقل
القصري جبرت اسرائيل مغادره حوالي 85 بالم
من الفلسطينيين من غزه فما من مكان امن
يذهبون اليه من لا يمكنهم التنقل او
يرفضون المغادره قتلوا او هم معرضين لخطر
ان يقتلوا في منازلهم فلسطينيون كثر نزحوا
اكثر من مره
والعائلات تضطر الى الانتقال مرارا
وتكرارا بحثا عن
الامان اوامر الاخلال الاولى في الثال عشر
من
اكتوبر طلبت او فرضت مغادره اكثر من مليون
شخص بمن فيهم الاطفال المسنين
المصابين مستشفيات
باكملها طلب منها اجلاء حتى الاطفال الرضع
في وحدات العنايه الفائقه فرضت اوامر
الاخلاء الانتقال من الشمال الى الجنوب في
غضون 24
ساعه الامر بحد ذاته يشكل اباده فهو تطلب
نقل فوري باخذ فقط ما يمكن حمله من دون
تقديم اي مساعده انسانيه او السماح
بتقديمها والمياه والوقود والغذاء والغذاء
ومتطلبات الحياه كانت مقطوعه عن قصد كان
ذلك يهدف الى تدمير الشعب وتهجير
الفلسطينيين بالنسبه لفلسطينيين كثر النقل
القصري من منازلهم دائم لقد دمرت اسرائيل
حتى الان ما يقدر ب
350 الف منزلا على الاقل وبذلك تترك على
الاقل نصف مليون فلسطيني من دون منزل
يعودون اليه المقرر الخاص لحقوق
الانسان الخاص بالنازحين
يفسر ان المنازل والمساكن مسحت وبذلك قضت
على اي احتمال واقعي لعوده النازحين
الفلسطينيين الى منازلهم وبذلك كرر تاريخا
من النقل القصري الجماعي
للفلسطينيين على يد اسرائيل ما من دلاله
على حتى الان ان اسرائيل عندها نيه اعاده
بناء ما تم تدميره على العكس الدمار يتم
الاحتفال به من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يصوروا الجنود انفسهم وهم
يحتفلون
بتدمير القرى والمدن ويرفعون العلم
الاسرائيلي فوق الانقاد وهم يسعون الى
اعاده اقامه
مستوطنات اسرائيليه على انقاد منازل
الفلسطينيين وذلك يعني الدمار او القضاء
على حياه الفلسطينيين في
غزه مع النقل
القصري تعمدت اسرائيل التسبب
بجوع وعطش
وتجويع الفلسطينيين الحمله التي تشنها
اسرائيل اودت بالفلسطينيين الى جوع شديد
حوالي 93% من من السكان في غزه وصلوا الى
مستويات ازمه في الجوع من بين كل الناس
حول
العالم الذين يعانون الان من الجوع
الكارثي اكثر من
80% موجودون في غزه الوضع سيء لدرجه ان
الخبراء يتوقعون الان ان عدد الفلسطينيين
الذين سيموتون في غزه نتيجه الجوع
والامراض اكبر الذين سيموتون جراء الغارات
ومع ذلك ما زالت اسرائيل تعرقل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى الفلسطينيين هي
لا تسمح بوصول المساعدات
[موسيقى]
وهي تقضي على امكانيه توزيعها من خلال
القصف المتواصل واعاقه الوصول منذ ثلاثه
ايام فقط في الثامن من يناير كان هناك
بعثه مخطط لها من الوكالات الامميه لتسليم
مستلزمات طبيه طارئه ووقود اساسي لمركز
تزويد
مستشفيات تم منعها من السلطات
الاسرائيليه شكل ذلك المره الخامسه التي
تمنع فيها البعثه من الوصول منذ ال 26 وال
من ديسمبر وبذلك هناك خمسه مستشفيات في
شمال غزه ليس عندها مستلزمات طبيه ثمانيه
شاحنات يسمح لها بالدخول ويتم الاستحواذ
عليها من
الجياع ما يتم تسليمه ليس
[تصفيق]
كافيا هذه صوره شاحنه محمله بالمساعدات
تصل الى
غزه
ثالثا تعمدت اسرائيل تسبب بظروف يحرم فيها
الفلسطينيون في غزه من الماوى المناسب
وال مياه الصرف الصحي والنظافه والملابس
على مدى اسابيع مضت كان هناك شح في هذه
المواد والمستلزمات المياه النظيفه غير
موجوده
وذلك يتسبب بنقص كبير في ما هو كاف من
المياه النظيفه الشرب وبذلك صرحت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان غزه تواجه نسبه عاليه
من تفشي الاوبئه والامراض المعيه بما فيها
حالات الاسهال بين الاطفال الذين عمرهم
اقل من خمسه خمس سنوات زادت نسبتها 2000
ضعف منذ بدايه الاعمال العدائيه عندما
تتراكم هذه الامور الامراض والجوع فاننا
ندخل في دوامه
قتل او دوامه
قاتله الفعل الرابع المرتكب هو الاعتداء
العسكري للجيش الاسرائيلي على نظام الصحي
او القطاع الصحي في غزه الامر الذي يجعل
من الحياه غير
ممكنه مقرر الخاص الاممي حول الحق بالحصول
على رعايه صحيه اشار الى ان البنى التحتيه
للرعايه الصحيه في في قطاع غزه تدهورت وتم
القضاء عليها من يصابون في غزه يحرمون من
الرعايه الطبيه التي من شانها ان تنقذ
حياتهم القطاع
الصحي مشلول نتيجه سنوات من الحصار لا
يمكنه ان يتعامل مع كميه وحجم
الاصابات وفي
النهايه المقرر الخاص حول العنف ضد النساء
والاطفال اشار الى فعل ترتكبه ما
اسرائيل يندرجان في الفئه الرابعه للافعال
التي تشكل اباده في الماده 2 د
للاتفاقيه في الاني من نوفمبر
حذرت من
التالي العنف
الجنسي الذي ترتكبه اسرائيل بحق النساء
الفلسطينيات والاطفال والرضع يرقى ليكون
فعل جريمه اباده بموجب الماده الثانيه في
اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه بما في ذلك
اجراءات تتخذ من اجل منع الولادات في
المجموعه تمنع اسرائيل تسليم المساعدات
الاساسيه بما
فيها المستلزمات الاساسيه للولادات في
حالات او في ظروف يتوقع فيها ان هناك 180
امراه ستلد في غزه
يوميا من هذه النساء ال
180 تحذر او تنذر منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
15% من شان هن ان يعانين من تعقيدات
مرتبطه بالولاده وسيحت جنا الى رعايه صحيه
طبيه اضافيه هذه الرعايه غير موجوده
باختصار سيدتي الرئيسه كل هذه الافعال على
حدا ومجتمعه تشكل نمطا
مدروسا لسلوك اسرائيل وتشير الى نيه
ارتكاب اباده هذه النيه واضحه من سلوك
اسرائيل في استهداف الفلسطينيين الذين
يعيشون في غزه استخدام الاسلحه التي
تسبب دمارا واسع
النطاق وذلك بالاضافه الى قنص هادف
للافراد تحديد مناطق امنه للفلسطينيين
ليلج اليها وبعد ذلك قصف هذه المناطق
حرمان الفلسطينيين من غزه من احتياجاتهم
الاساسيه الغذاء المياه الرعايه الصحيه
الوقود الصرف الصحي النظافه
والاتصالات تدمير البنى التحتيه
الاجتماعيه المنازل
المدارس المساجد الكنائس
المستشفيات
و
قتل الفلسطينيين والحاق الضرر بهم وترك
اعداد كبيره من الاطفال يتامه الابادات
الجماعيه لا يتم الاعلان عنها مسبق
ولكن هذه المحكمه امام اسابيع من الادله
التي تبين نمطا من السلوك والنيه
تبرر اتهام
بارتكاب اباده جماعيه في قضيه جامبيا
ميانمار لم تتردد هذه المحكمه في فرض
تدابير بالاستناد الى الادعاءات بان
ميانمار ترتكب افعال اباده ضد
الروهينجا وقائع امام المحكمه اليوم
للاسف اوضح ومثل ما كانت الحال في قضيه
جامبيا ميانمار تستحق وتتطلب تدخل هذه
المحكمه
يوميا هناك خسائر متزايده لا يمكن تعويضها
في الحياه والممتلكات والكرامه
وانسانيه الشعب الفلسطيني
تظهر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عندنا صور
لا يمكن ان نشاهدها بعد الان ما من شيء
سيضع حدا لهذه الافعال من دون امر من
المحكمه من دون تدابير التي تعلن عنها
ستتواصل الافعال مع العلم ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اشار الى انه ينوي مواصله هذه
الافعال على مدى سنه على الاقل
بكلمات الامين مساعد الامين العام للامم
المتحده في الربع في يناير
2024 اقبس تظنون ان ادخال المساعده الى
غزه سهل فكروا
مجددا ثلاثه مراحل من التفتيش قبل ان
تتمكن الشاحنات من الدخول ضياع و خط
انتظار طويل مواد كثيره يرفض ادخالها ممر
ضيق
للمشاه وليس للشاحنات وممر اخر اغلقته
المجتمعات الجائعه قطاع تجاري مدمر قصف
متواصل اتصالات ضعيفه طرق
متضرره شاحنات وقوافل يطلق النار عليها
تاخير عند نقاط
التفتيش شعب مصدوم تعب
يتم وضعه في قطعه ارض تضيق تضيق
وتضيق
عمال هم بانفسهم نزحوا او
قتلوا هذا وضع غير ممكن يعيش فيه
الفلسطينيون في غزه ومن يحاولون مساعدتهم
على الاعمال القتاليه ان تتوقف